what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
a video titled dating women made me
understand men before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring the notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos okay let's get this started
this video caught my attention because
it has like five million views so i was
like
she's gotta be saying something that men
resonate with
as you may remember i came out as
bisexual last year
and since then i have been dating women
and what i found
very fascinating is that the more i date
women
the more i find myself understanding
heterosexual men
let me explain exhibit a i was on a
first date with a girl who asked me out
by the way
this is relevant because when the check
came
she never once made a move to pay not
even like the fake let me reach for my
purse move
and though i don't mind paying on a date
part of me felt like you know the offer
would have been
nice i was also a little taken aback
that she didn't even say
thank you and damn i never heard from
her again
it really made me feel like she just
asked me out so she could have a free
dinner
and the moment i thought that i was like
oh my god i sound like all of my guy
friends
oh my gosh i've heard a lot of people
say that because i always say like women
are after like men's money
that's funny and my argument against why
guys should pay for dates has always
been like
look girls take hours to get ready our
investment
is looking really nice for you i i agree
with this
i 100 agree with that close that costs
money too
but we were both girls in this situation
we both took hours to get ready
so i definitely felt slighted exhibit b
on another date i went back to a girl's
house and i ended up making friends with
her cat
that's not a pun i'm talking about her
literal actual animal
and she said wow my cat never likes
anyone
i better go out and buy a wedding
[Laughter]
i don't dress where this is going
and again i felt like i got some serious
perspective
i have been guilty of making these kinds
of jokes on dates with men
i never really thought anything of it i
was a thing silly but then when i was on
the receiving end of it
yeah i suddenly understood the panic you
come off crazy i get that
that's fair one girl invited me back
into her house
and her specific words were do you
want to come in and make out obviously
i'm like yeah you're really pretty i
want to press my face to yours
but then when we got there we both just
sat on the couch and she talked
till like 3 a.m and i was like yo girl
i'm gonna wake up at like
6 a.m i was told there would be kisses
here there are no kisses
and like look i don't want to sound like
an [ __ ] like i don't mind talking i
love
talking but she could have said uh do
you want to come in and just
talk and i would have had totally
different expectations right
evening you know finally i started
falling asleep and i was like hey i
gotta go
and i gave her one kiss and and left and
i felt sad that the
amount of kisses promised did not equal
the amount
delivered and once again i felt like a
dude who was upset that i did not
receive the expected
physical kisses i was promised and i
wanted to talk about this because
i felt like this has really been
expanding my perspective when it comes
to dating
i finally understand a lot of the
complaints my male friends have about
dating that
i admit i would usually dismiss
but now i really get it when they say
dating is just so expensive man
sometimes i feel like a girl doesn't
even like me for me she just wants like
a boyfriend i wish it were more socially
expected to go dutch on the first few
dates but
you're like a jerk if you even suggest
it and any experience that expands your
compassion and understanding
is one that i think is worthy of sharing
so what about you have you had any
experiences that have shifted your
viewpoint dramatically
let me know okay actually this is a lot
of things
that she's complaining about or like she
was talking about i've actually heard in
the man of spirit it really
did in fact like make me understand a
little bit like the common complaints
you hear
about women um but oh my gosh
that was so funny that was a good little
skit let me know in the comments if you
guys
agree with it or you disagree and let me
know what video i should react to next
time
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and click the notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified for my daily videos